vivere in paesi diversi
mi mi fa sentire come un ponte un ponte
tra i territori che attraverso le
civiltà che attraverso e personalmente
per la mia esperienza personale questi
ponti costruisco attraverso le montagne
per molto tempo vissuto conflittualmente
questa molteplice identità che mi
caratterizza come caratterizza molte
altre persone sicuramente ma poi a un
certo punto questi aspetti sono
diventate una cosa sola e in quel
momento tutte le montagne e mi portavo
dentro sono fuoriuscite me ne sono
liberato in un certo senso hanno
cominciato a costruire dei ponti tra me
e il mondo a costruire ponti tra i mondi
mi trovo spesso ad attraversare il mondo
in posizioni piuttosto scomode cercando
il mare in una montagna una montagna nel
mare anche perché sul mare ci sono nato
aspettando di essere colto di sorpresa
da un'onda dove meno te l'aspetti o da
una slavina in un luogo come un immensa
pianura
utilizzo la l'arte per indagare dei temi
anche estremamente fragili come il
concetto di confine di appartenenza e di
identità e di conseguenza ciò che ne che
ne deriva tra nelle relazioni tra uomini
e territori
per me dipingere perché il mezzo che
prediligo
è come è come un certo senso trovare una
via in una montagna un appiglio sicuro
ma anche una via per scivolare via
veloci e un po quindi disegnare curve
nella neve e di segnare
il rincorrere visioni non dipinto per me
sono sono pressoché la stessa cosa ho
detto questa cosa perché sono un artista
e sono un allenatore di sci e oggi sono
qui a voler di raccontare un
mediterraneo a parlarvi di un
mediterraneo in una maniera un po
inusuale perché attraverso l'arte amo
anche un po spiazzare voglio raccontarvi
un mediterraneo visto dall'alto delle
sue montagne delle montagne che lo
circondano
e per fare questo voglio andare indietro
indietro di molto tempo indietro fino a
7 milioni di anni fa 7 milioni di anni
fa il mediterraneo era un immenso
deserto salato prosciugato senza acqua
per effetto della chiusura dello stretto
di gibilterra e in quel mare si vedevano
già però delle dorsali un sistema
scheletrico che collegava e collega
tutt'oggi i paesi e continenti che su di
esso si affacciano tra di loro poi circa
5 milioni di anni fa
l'apertura naturale con l'atlantico si
si riaprì e quindi il mediterraneo si
riempì di nuovo d'acqua e quelle dorsali
quella quel sistema scheletrico appunto
tenuto insieme dall'acqua rimase
sommerso coperto da questa da questa
superficie il il mar mediterraneo è
attraversato è circondato da 46 mila
chilometri di coste circa e altrettanti
sono i chilometri di catene montuose che
lo incorniciano letteralmente come come
un grande lago ed è molto importante
notare che l'altezza media dei paesi che
si affacciano sul mediterraneo è di
circa 2.700 metri la profondità media
del mediterraneo di circa 1500 metri
quindi
è evidente che le montagne rappresentano
una parte importante di questo dei paesi
che si affacciano su questo bacino e
altrettanto curioso e vedere che
l'italia posta come un cuore al centro
di questo mare che divide il versante
orientale da quello occidentale
appresso che la stessa altezza
dei paesi che che la circondano quindi
diventa quasi diventa quasi una terrazza
naturale in grado di dialogare a 360
gradi con i paesi che la circondano che
è un po la stessa cosa che sta avvenendo
oggi qui al ted con i relatori che che
provengono da vari paesi che si
affacciano sul mediterraneo
però io voglio raccontarvi
questo mediterraneo dalle montagne anche
attraverso attraverso un'esperienza
un'esperienza che ho iniziato che sto
vivendo da circa 4 anni 4 anni sulle
montagne del marocco sull'alto atlas del
marocco un'esperienza in cui ha fuso la
mia duplice competenza legata all'arte e
allo sci perché credo fortemente che la
costruzione di ponti sia determinata da
alcuni aspetti fondamentali che sono
appunto la competenza la passione la
condivisione e io aggiungerei anche la
delicatezza e rispetto
questi questi elementi analizzati
singolarmente da soli non funzionano
fusi insieme invece creano realmente
delle delle differenze il progetto che
che ho realizzato in marocco si chiama
atlas now ed è un progetto che appunto
unisce l'arte e lo sci e li utilizza
come strumenti di sviluppo relazione
sociale costruzione di relazione tra
uomini
di territorio di montagne e
anche era un modo per parlare di
un'africa diversa
spiazzare un pochino raccontare
un'africa fatta di ghiaccio e neve in un
paese fantastico come appunto è il
marocco dove le montagne sono veramente
maestose e questo progetto si realizza
attraverso una residenza per artisti
per maestri di sci per guida di montagna
e gli artisti
realizzano sul posto delle opere
utilizzando esclusivamente le risorse
locali
queste opere vanno a costruire un museo
un museo diffuso in tutti i villaggi e
le vallate del di questa regione
dell'atlas allo stesso modo e le guide i
maestri di sci sia locali che di altri
paesi che collabora con noi
fanno e realizzano dei programmi di
formazione tecnica specifica e per per
implementare delle attività di lavoro
sostenibili legate al territorio legate
alle attività propriamente vicine alla
montagna quindi nello specifico guide di
montagna e maestri scia cercando di
migliorare anche gli standard di
sicurezza relativi a queste attività è
tutto questo sviluppa aspetti importanti
una microeconomia locale certamente ma
anche una il processo costruttivo sia
delle opere deve rispettare dei principi
di collettività dei principi di rapporto
con l'altro di confronto continuo e di
conseguenza questo sviluppo a quei ponti
così così importanti però vorrei
accompagnarvi un attimo sulla trash
attraverso delle immagini per vedere una
piccolissima parte di quello di cui sto
parlando
guardiamolo insieme
ed è non è non è ancora finita questa è
solo una piccola sta una pinko un
piccolo intermezzo in questo contesto
che io considero in cui il consiglio è
importante anche riconsiderare gli
aspetti fondamentali legati all'arte
alla funzione dell'arte e alla funzione
di essere artista della società diventa
estremamente importante l'esperienza
vissuta dai dal ibrahim dal ibrahim è
una guida di montagna è un maestro di
sci marocchino che abbiamo invitato a
trascorrere un periodo di residenza in
italia è stata un'esperienza intensa
importante perché per me rappresenta
veramente uno spostamento reale di
confine uno spostamento reale di un
territorio un ponte tra le montagne i
due continenti ed al ibrahim
oltre che ad accrescere in con questa
esperienza le sue competenze tecniche e
condividerle con professionisti e guide
alpine italiane maestri di sci italiani
ha avuto la possibilità di poi
condividere tutto ciò con i suoi
connazionali con i professionisti del
suo paese e insieme hanno creato
un'associazione locale un'associazione
locale che gestisce le attività legate
alla montagna una piccola scuola legata
ai mestieri della montagna quindi in
grado di insegnare trasferire la
conoscenza e la relazione col territorio
alle generazioni più giovani
e stato molto bello vedere anche che
brahim dal suo paese ha trasportato una
pietra non è stato facile questa pietra
dove hai inciso dei messaggi dei
messaggi abbastanza importanti legate
all'ecologia alla natura ai popoli e ha
voluto lasciare questa pietra in una
sotto un albero isolato su un pendio
della montagna abruzzese questa pietra a
oltre un anno di distanza è ancora alla
testimoniare questa esperienza e questo
ponte che per me mira nel tempo a voler
unificare un po tutte le montagne del
mediterraneo cercando di creare un ponte
ideale per esempio tra la montagna più
alta che lo chiude a sud del to call sul
marocco appunto è la montagna che chiude
il mediterraneo a nord la più alta il
monte bianco ma ancora una volta voglia
accompagnarvi attraverso delle immagini
a mio parere molto belle che raccontano
un po l'esperienza di brahim vediamone
insieme anche queste
ed è
ed è con questa
con questa visione un po inusuale
dall'alto e alta del mediterraneo che
vorrei
concludere dare un piccolo contributo ad
annullare quei confini quasi sempre
convenzionali solo alla divisione di
popoli e territori quei confini che non
appartengono alla natura la natura cerca
sempre di ricreare un principio di
continuità e cosa appunto che vorrei in
un certo senso rappresentare attraverso
questo progetto attraverso il mio lavoro
ricreare quella continuità che poi è è
fondamentale per preservare la
differenza e la tolleranza
grazie